You are not going to ascend
in any organization
without a sponsor.
This person
who is going topound the
table on your behalf,
this is a sponsor.
It is the critical relationshipin your career.
Now, I'm asked all the time,
"How do you get one?"
Every time you deliver
upon an assignment
above people's expectations,
you generate performance currency.
Strongperformance currency
raises your level of visibility
in the environment,
such that a sponsor may
be attracted to you.
So it is important that you
invest the timeto connect,
to engage and to get to
know the people that are
in your environment,
andmore importantly to
give them the opportunity
to know you.
Because once they know you,
there's a higher probability that
when you approach them
to ask them to be your sponsor,
they will in fact answer
in the affirmative.